we already define work in one-dimension
is the product of force time
displacement for a constant force but
now let's look at a case where we're
applying a force F that is a function of
X so our component f of X is a function
of X in the IR direction and one of the
simplest examples of a force like this
is what we call the spring force now
when we apply this force to our object
and let's look at an object I I hat
direction will have an origin and this
is our plus x coordinate system now when
we apply a force what we want to look at
is because the force is a function of
position then we want to look at the
displacement over a small amount so
let's call this the point X J and out
here let's refer to this as X J plus 1
and what we've done is we're going to
ask how much work is done when the force
is displaced from here to there and
that's what we'll call Delta X so now
our displacement is a small displacement
X of J plus 1 minus X of J and our work
for this small displacement and that's
why we'll indicate it with a delta is
equal to the force which is a function
of x times this displacement and so now
we get f of X times X of J plus 1 minus
X sub J and what we have to indicate
here is because the force is varying
we're looking at just this displacement
here let's refer to this force as in the
J part now the total work is just the
sum of all these scalar quantities
remember although forces a vector and
displacement is a vector the product of
these two quantities is a scalar and so
if we want the total work we have to sum
Oh from J goes from 1 to N
of this quantity F of J I'll put a
little J there to indicate that Delta X
J now what is this some mean well
imagine that we're making a series of
displacements all the way out to a final
position X final and we divided this
interval into n pieces and so this now
represents the little bit of work done
for all of these displacements and that
is what we define to be the work for a
non constant force now the issue here is
about how fine we cut this interval and
we made n individual pieces but if we
want to ask ourselves what is the limit
as n goes to infinity then that's what
we now need to consider so what we're
doing is we're making smaller and
smaller and smaller little displacements
and we're taking this sum J goes from 1
to n of X of XJ times Delta XJ and this
limit of a sum is by definition the
integral of the force with respect to DX
so what we end up with is our work is
the integral of f of X now it's a
function and I'm going to have an
integration variable X prime of DX prime
where X prime is going from our initial
position to our final position and this
is now our definition of work Moore
which generalizes a constant force to a
non constant force now again let's try
to look at some type of geometric
interpretation so if we plot it f of X
verse X and now let's consider a case
where we have some arbitrary force so
I'm going to just draw the force as if
it were arbitrarily increasing as a
function of X and here's our X initial
and here's our X final
and again we would like to make a
geometric interpretation let's consider
XJ and I'll make this very big XJ plus 1
for the sake of visualization and this
value here is f of X J and so what we
see now is that little bit of work like
we had for a constant force can be
approximated as the area underneath the
curve for just this small interval
between XJ XJ and XJ plus 1 and if we
make this sum what we're doing is we're
just taking a series of approximations
to the area under these curves now you
can see graphically that there's very
little error when the function was
nearly constant but in this position
where the function is growing this
represents our little error however in
the limit as n goes to infinity we can
make that error go vanishingly small so
once again we see as a geometric
interpretation that this is the area
under the curve of the force versus
ition between the points the initial X I
and Nixle and the final X final where
the particle is being displaced from an
initial position to some final position
and here we can call our initial
position anywhere we want if I write
that as X initial to the final position
and that's our generalization of the
definition of work